all right tell the vaynernation who you
are Garrett green from Nashville
Tennessee I wanted to ask you talked a
lot about challenging the main media
source in your business I know you
brought up like companies bringing like
creating a golf website it takes on Golf
Digest and then every once in a while
has a sponsored post and I know you've
done it with cheese rank for smaller
companies they don't have all the
resources for editors and content
creators and such what you recommend for
them is this you think this is kind of
the next evolution it's gonna become
more of a product thanks for the
question it's a great question yeah I
mean look this is what I believe in and
for small businesses I recommend doing
what I did in 2006 which was look
there's a difference between BuzzFeed
and Seth codons blog right there's a lot
more content every day there's a lot
more stuff but Seth puts out his best
effort once a day for me I did a wine
show I mean it's what I'm doing right
now I mean in theory I could step up
even more than be rockin stunwin and and
put out Q&A shows all day long have go
the Oprah model and have people
underneath me there's a lot of ways to
go but if you believe in what I believe
in which is every business is becoming a
media company all of a sudden you're
taking hours away from staffing
strategizing selling all the other
things are doing and you're putting one
two three hours into becoming a media
company and I do believe that has
enormous upside I mean not much has
changed for me since I viewed the world
in 2009 and ROH crush it the only thing
that's changed is I'm even more
confident I was right because there's
more of that happening and look at the
average 50 the things I wrote about in
2009 that people thought was ridiculous
like you know a 15 year olds gonna have
more people that they think goes famous
on YouTube than in real life that's now
happening you know if anybody has 15
year olds let them in if anybody has 15
year olds in their lives hit him you
need me now I'm taping a show do I have
time oh those guys the guys I will but
let me bang out this show you know
you're not editing so to me I would just
say if you believe in it and you don't
have the resources then respect your
belief and put in your time and actually
do it versus all the other things you
could be doing oh crap wait subscribe
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social